what's the deal with airplane
peanuts the role of Comedy podcast
producer varies drastically in style
from getting fully involved in the show
look what I did for you you didn't do
that for me you did that for laugh to
quietly running things behind the scenes
Jamie what do you want to talk about
dude nobody ever asked jie that's true
you don't want to about he's a quiet
little guy there's no question a podcast
producer can completely change the vibe
of the show and when it comes to going
above and beyond to entertain the viewer
nobody did it better than [__] Lee Le
Lee Lee saat is sitting there his eyes
are shut Lee said something I go what
does that mean and he was
like see him lock up like the legend of
the flying Jew reaches far and wide as
Lee scat is one of the most beloved
producers from Comedy fans everywhere
turning a seemingly simple role on
Joey's podcast into one of the best
parts of the show over the years Lee
became much more than a producer of the
church he was his own character a viral
meme Joey's co-host and best friend and
even turned this opportunity into a
blossoming stand-up career of his own
all from a random message on Facebook so
Lee thank you so much for joining the
show today I was watching a clip of you
on stage recently actually talking about
how your job used to be getting really
really high on the internet so take us
back to the beginning how did you start
working for Joey Diaz originally and at
what point did the edible training start
it's great to be on the show I started
working with Joey I think it was June of
2011 I moved to LA from Boston uh I was
working on reality TV shows when I was
driving cross country I was on Facebook
one night in a hotel and I found I it
was either Doug Love's movies or um
Kevin Smith's podcast one of the guys I
worked with introduced me to Rogan I
heard Joey on a couple episodes and I
wrote to him on Facebook and I said I
want to work with comedians but I don't
want to come off as creepy and I got
lucky and Joey replied and it all went
went from there that's a pretty crazy
beginning just a a Facebook message uh
then all these years later knowing you
as like one of the main characters in
this podcast universe that's that's
crazy that that's how it all started we
just clicked and we we started out we
didn't even really do anything he asked
me what ideas I had and that turned into
mad flavors World which was a a a
YouTube I don't want to say series but
it was it was a series of videos right
we did a documentary we did a few CDs
and then the church and we we had a lot
of fun and and I'm proud of the work but
a lot of it came down to luck I just was
lucky that I I got the ball to send a
message and he answered and and all went
from there so the Church of what's
happening now officially ended around 3
years ago in the time that followed we
saw Joey move back to New Jersey and
start Uncle Joey's joint which is a new
podcast for him that you were featured
on a few times as a guest but besides
those appearances what were you up to
during that time post Church post church
was a fun nerve-wracking time I moved
back uh spent a couple months in
Milwaukee working on something that
didn't pan out I've been in
Massachusetts I lost a good amount of
weight I put a little bit back on
recently like knock on with not all of
it or nearly all of it but I put a
little bit back on and then I've been
working a day job and and working on
Comedy just trying to do and and get as
good as I can over the years has it ever
been more intimidating to get on stage
as a known person in the comedy world
but still needing to work on jokes as a
beginner in standup I don't think it's
intimidating the way I look at it
is I'm getting shows and opportunities
that most Comics at the I think around
the 5year mark probably wouldn't get I'm
not going to say that I I I always have
great sets or that I work as hard as I
can there's definitely things I could do
better I do take comedy seriously
because I want people who come out to
not just say oh he was that guy who got
high with Joey and the response that I
get from people who who loved the church
and and loved all that stuff is very
humbling and it's also a little bit not
surprising but it's not something that I
you know I lived in the same apartment
in La I didn't go to Hollywood Hills
parties I didn't go to any I didn't go
to any premieres so to hear that so many
people loved and and liked and had fun
with what we did is is is crazy I saw
like a seven minute video of that you
posted of you on stage it was hilarious
it seemed really well written and
performed I Johnny was telling you I was
a post of podcast for about 10 years my
job was to get really really high on the
internet my mom is very proud of me
I used to take about 2,000 Mig a
night that is she said you look
terrified you look like my doctor when I
walked
in it was too many milligrams it
was I I don't recommend it at that
amount at 2,000 Mig they turned into
performance-enhancing
drugs like I would do real like really
just terrible
things you guys don't seem to this is
the day I woke up and I knew I had a
problem and I had to slow it down is I
woke up one morning and I thought i'
poop the
[Music]
bed I didn't poop the
bed what I did do is I did fall asleep
on a Kit Kat
bar how has stand up been going for you
recently yeah thank you it was it you
know posting stuff on YouTube as you
know can be a scary thing and I'm not
very patient I'm always like I don't
know about you but I always leave about
20 30 seconds on the microwave like I
can never wait for it to get to zero and
that's how I am with almost everything
so in my mind why am I not you know on
the road every weekend Josh Wolf who was
a guest on the church many times has
brought me out to open for him and and
that's been going fantastic and starting
to do a little bit around here with the
local clubs I had my first show at a
Chinese place yesterday it was like a
1:00 show on a Sunday which sounds
terrible it was a great show the
audience was there to have fun and the
comics were great Joey talked about it
on the church I'm starting to see every
every few months a little bit of a step
up and I've had people tell me that my
jokes have gotten tighter it's nice to
see the work paying off a little bit
little by little well you just recently
started a new podcast with Joey called
the check-in how does that feel moving
from the producer seat to the full-time
official co-host of the show just a few
years later it's pretty I I never
thought I'd be a co-host of anything
when we started the church I didn't want
to be on camera or on the mic I wanted
to let Joey go crazy and I've been
having a lot of fun with the checkin
it's a it's different we have we have a
lot of fun we have a lot of laughs you
know the the reason why we called it the
checkin is because that's what Joey does
with me and everyone is he he checks in
on on people we know that there are a
lot of people who who could use that
right now and who were fans of and and
listen to the church and you know we're
not trying to be the number one podcast
we're just trying to to have fun
genuinely be who we are and talk about
things that we're interested in and you
know just have a little bit of fun every
week that's awesome I feel like that
authenticity is really shining through
and people are super interested to see
you guys back together and like you in a
official co-host role too where you guys
were just chatting like when you would
be a guest on Uncle Joey's joint even
though you got definitely your shine in
the church too it's nice to see you in
that full just second seat last question
before I let you go here Lee from what
you can remember uh from filming the
church do you have a favorite moment or
memory from producing the Church of
What's Happening Now Ralphie May with
like with focus on the yellow has to be
one of the best meeting Gabriel glaus
was was fantastic Mike Tyson was
fantastic uh Henry Rollins was super
very kind to me one of my favorite
moments one of the times that we had
Dice Clay on was fantastic because after
the podcast he he just we he was sitting
next to me and dice looked over and said
hey have you ever thought about doing
standup and I hadn't I had never done
standup didn't think I was that kind of
funny and that was my like impetus I
guess for starting standup wow that's
when I I went to open mics and and Joey
told me about the fourth wall and it
went from there so for better or worse I
guess you can blame Dice Clay for me
starting stand but who knows maybe he
asks everyone that that would be funny
if he was just asking everyone that this
whole time I saw a few months ago I was
watching two bears one cave with I I
think it was theovon and Tom sagora and
they just started talking about you in a
really positive way does that feel
insane to see two of the most famous
comedians on the internet at least let
alone just in the comedy World start
talking about you out of the blue both
of those guys were always super nice to
me thinking about it when I left La Theo
called me one day just out of the blue
just checking in on me last night at at
the Wilbur I heard people talking about
Bert and I know that a lot of people
they spend a lot of time with us they
spend a lot of time watching videos and
and podcasts and going to shows and
you're never really sure how these
people are in real life and I'm not
saying that there aren't [__] I'm
sure that there are some comedians that
that you're watching and they might be
[__] for the 99% of the ones that I
was lucky enough to to meet on the
church and and throughout all this have
been very very nice to me very kind I I
have no illusions of being one of the
biggest comedians in the world if I
could be a headlining comedian like in
the same world as them if I could be at
the at the top level clubs that would be
an honor so it's uh it's great that they
they talk about me in a positive way and
and they like what I did and they like
to me so it means a lot well Lee thank
you so much for joining the show today
thank you so much for your time uh what
do you want the people to know where to
find you any upcoming shows in the
Boston area or just any you know closing
remarks thank you honestly if you're
watching this and you like to the church
thank you it means a lot I had a ton of
fun it changed my life the check-in with
Joey uh we do it it comes out every
Tuesday please go check it out um it's
just as Joey likes to say two fat [__]
shooting the [__] we're having fun I
don't have any dates yet but I I'm going
to be opening up for Josh Wolf sometime
next year so keep and go see him anyways
even if if I'm not going to be there but
January 19th Nashville Tennessee I'm
going to be at the eastom 700 p.m.
please come out tickets are 10 bucks
it's my first time anyone's brought me
anywhere to headline and I'd love it to
be full at a small room the East room in
Nashville January 19th all right that
got me pumped up thank you again Lee
thank you if you want to hear even more
about Lee's new podcast with Joey Diaz
called the check-in you can find a full
recap video that we posted to our second
channel on the end screen right after
this also on that end screen will be the
interview we just did with Tom sigora it
would mean a lot for you guys to go
check that out and tell me what you
think in the comments also I would
highly recommend checking out the full
clip of Lee's performance over on his
YouTube channel and while you're there
be sure to tell him joke World sent you
thanks for
watching at joke
world that's it
world and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out